today we're going to be speaking with
Erica engelhopt who's a science
journalist living in Washington DC and
also author of the book gory details
Adventures from the Dark Side of science
Eric a really great having you on I
appreciate it thanks nice to be here so
you know we've spoken over time about
everything from you know Homeopathy to
drinking silver Faith healing old sorts
of Medical Treatments that maybe kind of
worked at one point but there are now
better options compared to out and out
scams Etc one of the things you talk
about in the book is the relation
between medical myths misconceptions and
irrational Health fears and this sense
of disgust that as humans we could say
has been developed or has been bred in
or however you sort of want to say it
let's maybe start there talk a little
bit about the the tendency towards
disgust and how it might predispose
people to some of these medical
misconceptions
yeah I think you know discuss
those kind of overlooked emotions um
something that we don't necessarily
think about or talk about a lot
um but oh you know some psychologists
would say that it's one of the basic
human emotions it seems to be Universal
at least the feeling of disgust
um you know there are certain particular
signs of disgust that people around the
world give you know that kind of
squinched up face
um you know kind of expelling something
out of your body like yeah like 80 of
the way to gagging we might say exactly
exactly and that's something that you
know people around the world uh
experience that feeling of disgust but
in terms of what things are considered
disgusting that's really kind of up for
grabs culturally so that is something
that we we tend to learn as we grow up
so there may be something where humans
as a species have evolved the sense of
disgust probably as a protective
mechanism because because a lot of the
things that disgust us are things that
could hurt us right things that could
make us sick for example
um so you know we we learn uh we teach
most of our children around the world
you know not to eat their poop
um and you know maybe as babies they
they're not disgusted by poop and
they'll stick their hands right in it
but we we you know we teach our kids to
be disgusted by the smell and and
appearance of poop and most of us around
the world get that at some point in our
lives so
um but there are a lot of other things
that vary from you know from place to
place culture to culture
um especially when it comes to things
like food so every culture has some food
that it thinks is delicious and that
other cultures think is totally
disgusting yes um so that's so it's
relative so there are things that
um are pretty universally disgusting
those tend to be the things that could
hurt us or make us sick and then there
are other are things that are just
you know we decide basically that
something is disgusting and something is
not disgusting and so then what's the
connection from that to the medical
myths and misconceptions yeah so disgust
is a really powerful feeling and so
since we have this you know strong
aversion to certain things
um that means that it can really kind of
guide our decisions and shape our
thinking about things and a lot of the
things that were disgusted by
um involve our bodies you know a lot of
things involving bodily functions
um you know all of our bodily secretions
and excretions
um Blood Sweat tears you know it's not
these are things that you don't
necessarily
um
you know they're very intimate and
they're generally considered disgusting
if they're coming from a stranger right
sure
um so we're not necessarily disgusted
um so much by our own body fluids and so
forth but we're certainly disgusted by
uh those of strangers and so when you
think about you know some of the
different kinds of
um Medical
Treatments and products things that
people are trying to sell to us it's
very easy to play into that sense of
disgust for example there's a huge
industry built around the idea of
detoxifying our bodies yes purifying
cleansing all of these things are
basically meant to make us less
disgusting we all want to be less
disgusting right we all want to have
um this idea of being you know clean and
pure but
when it comes down to it you know a lot
of these things are playing on our
disgust of our of our bodies or other
people's bodies
um and really are not selling us
something that's real you know uh again
you know it's easy to play on that
disgust and say like oh this is going to
detoxify you yeah
um and and that sounds good and if we
see for example if you you know there
are
um
certain kinds of sweat therapy that that
uh people are selling really hard and
the idea is that you can sweat out the
toxins and if people see something
coming out of their bodies it feels like
satisfying it feels like you're getting
something bad out
um yeah I've told stories of uh I don't
do it often because I find it painfully
awkward but I've had like professional
massages before and the massage goes
great and at the end they say you know
the massage will loosen a lot of the
toxins in the body so you should drink a
lot of water and I'm thinking wait a
second so the water is processed and the
kidney what's the mechanism here that's
going on but it's sort of that same idea
where it's like that sounds it sounds
generally good yeah like I mean that I I
could kind of go for that you know
Jonathan height has written about the
connections between disgust and
political leanings and predispositions
and I'm I'm wondering whether when it
comes to medical myths misconceptions
quack cures and openness and this sort
of thing whether there are other maybe
personality traits or whatever that that
we may be able to overlay on whether
it's politics or upbringing or whatever
the case may be yeah yeah I mean
definitely people there's a range in how
easily disgusted people are some people
are very sensitive to disgust and are
very easily triggered uh to feel
disgusted others not so much I've had
seem to have a pretty high tolerance for
disgust for example because I write
about gross things yes
um but you know a lot of people don't
and there have been some studies like
what you're referencing that link those
traits how easily disgusted you are to
various other kinds of opinions that we
form and so some in general
um and I don't want to make this any
kind of hard and fast rule but
um some Studies have found a connection
between people who are more easily
disgusted and people who tend to be more
conservative political leaning yes
um and it kind of makes sense if you
think about the idea of um you know that
a person who is very
um easily triggered to feel discussed
might be kind of sensitive and afraid of
things that uh could cause that feeling
and so things that are different things
that are outside
um you know may be more triggering to
some people than to others
um I think the same kind of thing
happens
you know perhaps with these kinds of
um Health beliefs and misconceptions
um some people seem to be just more
sensitive and more triggered by the idea
of being contaminated
by something
um by you know things that are dirty
um and that can also be likewise that
can be played back into politically you
know I one of the interesting things
about this that you're making me think
of is you know there's a lot of I think
we can all understand how
if indeed this higher sense of or this
more easily triggered disgust aligns
with political conservatism we could see
how that might make people against
immigration right we hear stories about
I mean Tucker Carlson once overtly said
immigrants make make the country dirtier
and poorer that's literally something
that you would be disgusted by the dirt
that he said okay that that one's super
clear it's been interesting to see with
the pandemic
you would think germs around me you
would you would think that with a more
easily triggered disgust response the
right would have been more sensitive to
the idea of the germs of covid but for
political reasons and for other reasons
it hasn't actually been the case
right yeah I think that's an interesting
point too
um you know but disgust can cut a lot of
different ways and you know we have to
remember that it can be discussed can
also be weaponized right uh you know it
can be turned against certain groups of
people like you were saying it's often
turned against immigrants saying oh
they're diseased and dirty
um and they're coming in here and
they're contaminating our population in
some way yes
um you know the same kind of thing can
happen with covid where there's you know
marginalizing of certain groups because
they're seen as the cause
um you know so we saw that with with
Asian Americans
um earlier in the pandemic and so forth
um and so you know I think that the
disgust can be weaponized in whatever
way is convenient for a particular you
know political groups interests
so sometimes you get things that are
sort of nonsensical you know where it
seems like people are really acting
against their own best interests yeah or
even their predispositions but
interestingly there was a sense of
disgust about the masks by some of the
folks who did not see right the feeling
of the mask and it's restricting my
breathing and I'm rebreathing My Own
carbon dioxide related to this does
one's willingness to accept a medical
myth treatment you know scam treatment
or whatever the case may be relate to
how disgusted or put off they are by
whatever it is they are trying to treat
if that makes sense in other words
when you maybe learn more about
something you would be less likely to
fall for the misinformation and the
quack cures
necessarily hard data
and um
I will cite an example of
um kind of a more extreme version yeah
so for example people who are already
easily
um sensitized or disgusted by insects
and afraid of uh you know people some of
us are totally freaked out by insects or
spiders
um some of us you know
not so much
um there's a condition called delusions
of infestation that I have um
have worked on for for several years now
and
um it's it's really upsetting it's where
people develop the idea that insects
um or other small creatures have in have
literally infested their bodies right
and and it often starts with something
real like an itch it could be as simple
as a skin condition that's causing an
itch but because people some people are
already
kind of worried about insects or just
sort of more prone to to feel discussed
about insects if they happen to see an
insect in the environment they may make
the connection that oh I think that's
what's going on here I think that I've
got these insects attacking me right and
so I think that's kind of an extreme
example of where someone who maybe is
already kind of predisposed to a certain
kind of of disgust or feeling about
about insects you know may be more
likely to develop this
extreme delusion which can be
you know completely devastating where it
takes over people's lives and you know
their lives really become about trying
to prove to everyone else yeah that this
infestation is real yeah my dad's a
psychiatrist and he's he's dealt with
that and talked to me about it some
sometimes that that does respond quite
well to medication interestingly enough
now the interesting thing is that
relates to something else I've said
before which is you know we've talked a
lot about conspiracy theories on the
show yeah and we'll sometimes say you
know how does someone fall into
is it flat Earth or is it you know more
recently with relation to covid stuff
about vaccines how is it they end up
with that as opposed to something else
and very often it's sort of
environmental and Circumstance
circumstantial it's listen because of
the media environment and the people
that they're around and where they live
they're into does injecting bleach cure
covid as opposed to something about the
bilderbergs or flatter so there's like
an invite but they are predisposed
generally to this type of thinking it
seems that with some of the things
you're talking about there might also be
a similar idea where it's not I mean I
don't know it seems that someone who
falls into what you just described about
the insects would be predisposed to
something else if it was environmental
or or around them culturally
right exactly
exactly kind of what psychologists call
magical thinking yes
um you know we none of us are perfectly
logical beings and so we all have these
kinds of beliefs and misconceptions
going on all the time
um about something
about something and you know magical
thinking it can be um you know
psychologists talk about the the law of
similarity and the law of contagion
um which relate to disgust because you
know the law of similarity says the
image is the object and so that's the
that's the kind of thinking that makes
for example
um
burning an effigy uh a very powerful
statement because it you know in our
minds deep in our lizard brain somewhere
it really feels like when you burn the
symbol of the person you're harming the
person it's it's what makes uh voodoo
doll satisfying to stab and it's also
related to disgust it's what makes
poop-shaped chocolates not a big hitch
right right because we associate the
disgusting thing of poop with the
chocolate even though the chocolate is
perfectly fine to eat
um and so you know those kind that kind
of thinking can come in to our basically
our beliefs about health and wellness
and and all of these things as well and
and certainly I think that that
indicates something about our belief
systems more broadly and so certainly I
think it makes sense to me that
um you know there there are these kind
of deeper reasons in our thinking that
we're all vulnerable to why we might be
susceptible to certain myths and
misconceptions and then our environments
and our society you know our culture the
people that we're around shape the
details of those things the book is Gory
details Adventures from the Dark Side of
science we've been speaking with the
book's author Erica engelhop who's a
journalist living in Washington D.C
Erica really appreciate your time and
insights today
thank you so much great to be on